hello everyone and welcome to a really
incredible game that was just played
in the mr doji invitational it is a most
prestigious event that is currently
taking place on the chess 24 play zone
it's a 16 player knockout
with some of the well some of the
strongest players in chess today
and we're going to discuss that a little
bit later but now let's just focus on
the game as that's
why you guys are here and it's a really
really incredible one
all of these are blitz games so five
minutes per player without
any increment uh so real chess here uh
happening
and uh well again by the number of
messages i received i immediately knew
that this was going to be an
uh an excellent game so without further
ado let's check it out so it
doesn't happen to any of you adiban with
the white pieces faces david navarra
and adiban of course with the white
pieces always plays
b3 as he made a chessable course on it
uh which i
imagine everyone knows uh by now so
b3 are going for his nimzovich larsen
attack we have
e5 a very principled reply just striking
in the center
bishop to b2 we have knight to c6 and
now
while the most played move here is e3
then you want to play some like maybe
bishop b5
grab this knight open up the b file you
will give black uh
the b file for the rook but you already
have a nice fiance bishop
on the queen side and it's not going to
be a problem so this is how you might
play it
uh adiban goes for c4 instead there's
the second most popular line and
now knight to f6 and again uh ariban is
waiting with
this e3 idea so he develops the knight
knight to f3
and now it's uh he's basically baiting
black to
advance this pawn all the way to e4
because the pawn is under attack
so you have to either defend it or you
know not move it
so here e4 attacking adiban's knight
knight to d4 and now bishop to c5 so
developing with tempo
the knight on d4 is nicely attacked and
now uh not
grabbing the knight on c6 and that
doesn't really do anything yes you do
double black spawns but it's not really
like i said gaining anything so knight
to f5
attacking that g7 pawn and here you're
basically helping black black is just
going to castle here black is going to
play d5 with a double attack on the pawn
on the knight here on
on f5 uh or maybe not so here we have
castles and
now finally e3 by adiman we have
d5 now striking in the center attacking
that c4 pawn
while exposing this knight to the attack
from the bishop and now what do you play
here
here uh adiban grabbed on d5 now saying
okay you capture my
knight on f5 i'm gonna capture this
knight on c6 and although this isn't the
the
greatest move for black it's a much
better than what actually happened in
the game
uh best for black is just to play knight
b4 now okay you're gonna recapture this
pawn later on and everything is
perfectly fine here
however uh if this happened we probably
wouldn't be showing this game in this
game
knight captures on d5 was played and
this is a problem because
only eight moves were played so far but
adiban has a forced
checkmate in four moves so feel free to
pause the video and
win this game for adiban in the short as
possible
wait while i give you a couple of
seconds
well while i said this someone just
replied
with a comment on my previous video feel
free to pause the video
so that's pretty that's pretty cool uh
but yeah uh congratulations to everyone
who found it as it's not
that uh you know easy move to find a
grandmaster like nevada missed it and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's queen to
g4 this is what adiban played and it was
in this position on move nine uh in 2021
that grand master david navarro resigned
in the game as there is nothing more to
be done here
checkmate is being threatened and the
problem is you cannot eliminate the
knight
because the checkmate is also being
threatened by the queen and the bishop
so this is just the queen captures and
g7 checkmate
and other than that if you don't capture
the knight there's no way to defend
checkmate
you could play something like g6 yes
this does prevent queen characters in g7
but
then comes knight to h6 checkmate and
now the bishop covers all the dark
squares the knight delivers check
and that's just it there's no there's no
uh the defense against this
so really really incredible stuff and uh
i don't know
it's just amazing that such a game can
still happen but that's the beauty of
blitz chess and that's the beauty of no
increment chess you know things just are
a little bit faster and you know
uh and you know great things happen like
this
uh so yeah thank you guys for suggesting
such a lovely game i i really enjoyed it
hope you guys did as well and
i imagine more and more people are gonna
start playing b3
uh audiban being the cause of that no
doubt uh so you know uh
do do share your own experiences in the
comments and if you were able to win
such uh uh such wonderful games uh i
would like to thank joseph myers
michel uh new zealand
alexander hixson and david kimura for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will
uh see you soon continuing the coverage
of the mr dodgy invitational
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day